how did I find my passion I'm going to
answer that question in today's episode
of lunch and earn sorry Scott asked the
question for one of my loyal YouTube
viewers love you guys Kyle who wrote in
to say how did you find your passion and
what were the difficulties that you face
in your journey here and how did you
deal with it this is a great question
and I've told this story a couple of
times but I feel like it's been a while
so i'll address it again in this context
and the difficulties along the way in my
first business it was about to software
company and i joined as an owner with
two other founders and at that time I
wasn't you know my passion wasn't making
that software it wasn't the the good
that we were doing I didn't have a
software background I didn't have a
science background I was super green and
it was a struggle for me to kind of
learn the business and be able to market
it and promote it but my passion there
was in helping these two entrepreneurs
build their business I discovered that I
really love doing that and when we sold
the company I went into a almost
oppression of what am I gonna do next
you know like I don't know what I want
to do and I bounced around a lot of
different opportunities and follow my
own advice which is if you don't know
what you want to do explore and try
things and see what makes you come alive
and how I discover this right this
helping entrepreneurs this thing that
I've been doing for I don't know 12 plus
years now is I got invited to to speak
at a YMCA to help their entrepreneur
program there's a bunch of young
entrepreneurs going through the program
and i went up to that first event and I
thought I've got so much great
information to share all the lessons
that I learned and all the mistakes that
I made and how to help them really
become successful entrepreneurs and it
was a free event and only three people
showed up and that was that was really
heartbreaking for me because I felt like
maybe this is my next thing you know
like maybe helping entrepreneurs is my
next next big move maybe that's what I'm
really you know that's my real passion
and only three people showed up and it
was really disheartening and I felt like
at that time and this is this is a total
failure right like I was flown in this
event the YMCA was phone in the event
and
and nobody shows up for a free thing how
am I ever going to charge for how am I
ever gonna make money how am I ever
going to turn this into a career and I
decided in that moment that would keep
going right that I would help those
three people and it just felt so amazing
helping those people seeing their eyes
light up having them leave the room
feeling not just motivated encouraged
but also having ideas that they could go
and actually now build their business
and knowing that I had an impact that
that meant something real to me and I
knew that I had to find a way to keep
going it was from that moment it may
become so alive that I had to find a way
to keep doing this and I didn't care if
I way didn't care but I didn't know if
I'd ever make money I didn't know if I'd
ever be successful in that but I knew
that I loved it so much i just i love
that high of helping entrepreneurs that
i had to find a way to keep doing it
even if that meant doing some other
things well i tried to figure out my
path i would for sure keep this as one
of the things that I did so that was I
think the biggest struggle for me was
just knowing that I love something and
knowing how excited i got buy it but not
knowing how I'd ever turn it into a
business not knowing how I never support
myself doing this and because I loved it
because it was genuine I kept doing it
and I kept doing more presentations and
more events and all of them for free
because I didn't have a business model
behind it that just I fed off the energy
and it started to grow and I had you
know five people the next one at ten
people the next 12 15 and 20 and 30 and
50 and it just kept growing and then
launched my website and then I got asked
to speak at different events and then I
started to get paid to speak and wasn't
a lot of money a couple hundred dollars
maybe but like wow you want to pay me to
calm sure happy to and then I started
increasing my speaking fee and a lot of
it is because while i was driving more
awareness i was building up a name for
myself and to with more practice I got
better right my my speeches now are way
better than they were at the start and
so I can justify charging a lot more
money now than I could when I first
started and it gradually grew from there
and I think YouTube was one of the when
I started on YouTube and when I really
went all in on YouTube that's when it it
hit me that i'm finding something i
absolutely love doing because i would
answer emails for people and i would
spend i would spend like an hour writing
somebody back an email if you ask me
this question i would spend an hour
sitting there writing an email to
respond to you and I was getting too
many emails and I'm much more of a
visual person I thought why don't I turn
this into a video i started my channel
and you guys have been the fuel to keep
me going and i'm responding the videos
and making you guys grow your businesses
and giving you helpful advice and tips
and wisdom and ideas and that has now
accelerate my business where i'm getting
opportunities with brands i'm getting
international speaking deals and i have
a book deal and so I face the same
challenge that a lot of you guys are
facing now we're at the beginning you
have this love you have this passion
excitement for something that you're
doing and you don't know how you're
gonna make it work and you feel
everything that you try doesn't bring in
enough dollars to support yourself and
the key is just to keep going if you
keep going you will figure it out and
all the plans that I had you know you
always start with a plan you have a plan
I think this is the perfect plan is how
it's going to work it never actually
worked out like I planned it would work
out what it did eventually work out
because I kept going because I kept
changing because they kept adapted
because they kept improving because I
kept providing value and people started
to care more and more and more and more
and more and so I found like circling
back to the question I found my passion
by accident by a fluke by just saying
yes to opportunities right the ymca
event was one thing that i did that i
said yes to i said yes to a whole bunch
of other stuff too just because i was
honestly desperate and just trying to
find something that would make me come
alive and salsa was one of those things
too when i fell in love with salsa but i
did not fall in love with a whole bunch
of other stuff that I try and so if
you're trying to find your passion
continue to explore find something that
makes you come alive and when you find
it latch onto it keep doing it and
you'll eventually find the way to make
money I promise you believe so that's my
story I'd love to know what your story
is how did you
find your passion leave in the comments
below I'm really curious to find out
thank you so much for watching you team
to believe and I'll see you soon